Earlier in the course we saw how object oriented analysis can give you
a better understanding of the problem you are trying to solve.
The results is a set of diagrams, interface specifications, expressed in OCL,
and a list of non-functional requirements and
constraints. Then the architectural design process can help you determine
appropriate subcomponents. Understand the tradeoffs among the constraints.
Select appropriate methods for satisfying the nonfunctional requirements. And
choose a suitable architectural style. The eventual target is to
produce a program written in some object oriented language like Java.
The purpose of this lesson is to introduce you to Object Oriented Design,
OOD. The process of getting you from your analysis and
intended architecture to the point where you can write the target program.